this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your
relationships your work
everything that matters to you i'm
george campbell ramsay personality and i
will be your host today with no co-host
that's right i'm flying solo and i want
to talk i want to talk about your money
i want to talk about what you're worried
about what you're excited about
on this show we dive into
the lowest points of people's lives we
celebrate the highest of highs with them
and we talk about everything in between
so if you've got a question give us a
call the number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five and if you
are let's say under 25 years old i wanna
give you a quick pro tip here pull out
your phone there's a app that says phone
and you tap that and then you're gonna
dial triple eight eight two five five
two two five our friend austin is gonna
pick up in the booth and he will patch
you in and we can talk about things
maybe you want some confirmation maybe
you need some affirmation maybe you just
need a third party who's a little
unbiased to tell you that you're doing
great or maybe i can slap you around a
little bit and walk you off a ledge
that's what i'm here for justin is going
to kick us off this hour he's in tampa
florida justin welcome to the show
hey george how are you doing great my
man how can i help
so quick question for you i'll give you
i guess a brief background
i am on baby step four
and i'm going to be getting married uh
this december
and when i get married
my fiancee and i are going to be
starting out in baby step two
and so just kind of trying to think
about our living situation right now i'm
anticipating my rent going up here the
next couple months when my lease is up
and so my question for you is my parents
have actually offered to i guess buy a
house
for my fiance and i and allow us to live
there and pay them
the mortgage um and then when we're able
to get our debt paid off and save up a
down payment we could then buy the house
from them um didn't know if that was a
good idea um you know honestly kind of a
prideful person and don't really like
the idea of them buying a house for me
because i want to feel like i've done it
on my own but
i don't just wanted to see what your
thoughts were on it
that's a great question man there's a
lot of wisdom just in the way that
you've been talking and how you said hey
we're going to be in baby step 2 once we
get married because she's coming in with
debt and it's going to become we
and the question really becomes what's
what's the relationship like with your
parents and are you going to be okay
with this decision
so my
relationship with my parents i don't
know if they could get any better to be
honest with you i'm really open about
our finances
together um you know they do my taxes
for me because they're accountants
um
you know so i mean we're really all on
on the on the same page i just i don't
know part of me
wants to feel like i did it all on my
own and not ask for help but then the
other part of me says well if this is
going to help us get out of debt faster
then maybe it's not a bad idea now are
they in a financial place to buy another
house do they have their mortgage paid
off
uh yeah
so they're in baby step seven paid for
house and they just want to kind of
bless you guys by creating the situation
where you can rent and then one day buy
it from them
yes that's very kind of them well what
here's what i'm wondering about are they
going to charge you market rent
are they going to charge you uh yes
way less than they could make oh no no
no it would be it would be we would we
would just pay them whatever the
mortgage
payment is
um
up until we were able to buy the house
from from them and then just kind of
take it over from there okay but you
don't know what that what that amount
will be yet
i don't i mean i i haven't really gone
into the weeds with them yet you know on
what the price range of the house would
be or anything like that mostly because
i haven't
really felt like i i wanted them to do
this
not to sound like a broken record but
because i wanted to do one on my own
that's what i keep going back to man it
sounds like you're gonna even if this
all works out perfectly you're still
gonna sit there and go man i don't feel
like i did that quite on my own it feels
like i got a little handicap there and i
kind of got to leapfrog a step so i
don't think there's anything wrong with
either situation but i think you're
leaning towards pulling yourself up by
the bootstraps and doing the hard work
and saving up the down payment and being
patient and i think that's there's a lot
of wisdom in that
what do you know what your income will
be when you're married
um it'll probably be
if it was based on
income from last year it'll be about
150. 1000. but i expect that to go up
dude that's incredible well here's what
i'm thinking you guys have a great
income you're gonna pay off her debt
pretty soon right it's not gonna take
longer than a few years two years
i don't even think it'll take
that long i've
done a pretty good job of saving up
money on on my own and so my goal is to
with the the progress that she makes
this year
um and then when we get married and
combine finances by i'm hoping by that
time i'll just be able to write checks
and pay it all off
well i think you have this conversation
with mom and dad and you say hey thank
you so much for your generous offer i
love you guys i love the way you've
raised me i appreciate this but we want
to do this on our own and we want to
kind of start this new chapter and
that's no dis to you we just i really
want to do this on my own to prove to
myself that we can do this and that
we're financially set and that seems
like the route that's going to leave you
the happiest
would you agree all right
yeah i would i don't know you know i
just
if uh
the math part just starts popping in my
head to where you know if we could get a
slightly lower
mortgage payment than a rent payment
would that allow us to make you know
maybe a little bit more if i'm not able
to save up all the money necessary by
the end of the year um how old are you
yeah what a lower
25. yeah you're doing great man there's
no rule that says you have to have a
house at 25 and you have to have a house
as soon as you're married i think it's
totally fine to rent for a while and get
to know your your new spouse and just
hang out and you're going to have a
whole bunch of quirks to figure out just
with being married the last thing you
need on top of that is kind of this
weird
quasi-homeownership with mom and dad
tied to it and there's a relational
element but there's this business
transaction that needs to happen and i
think it's going to be better for
everyone if you just do it on your own
okay yeah dude perfect yeah good luck
with it congrats hey can i give you a
wedding present
do you have ramsay plus right now
uh i do my fiance does not boom okay
well let's get you one year of ramsay
plus is she on board with the plan
she is well she's going to be extra on
board now so i want you guys to watch
fpu together all those financial piece
university videos has she seen them
before
no okay this is going to be a game
changer for you guys this is the best
pre-marital counseling i can give you is
to watch all nine lessons of financial
peace university jump onto every dollar
plus our premium budgeting tool make
your first budget together when you guys
are married later this year and then
start making a plan for what this looks
like hey how fast we're gonna pay off
this debt how fast are we gonna build
the emergency fund we're going to start
investing and saving for the down
payment you guys get a plan for your
lives together and your marriage is
going to be great regardless of your
parents helping you out
so hang on the line man that would be
awesome austin's going to pick up
congratulations on the impending wedding
on the impending house purchase you guys
are doing great we need more justin's in
this world hey this is the ramsay show
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five i'm george
campbell we'll be back with you
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print podcast and the entree
leadership podcast all of which you can
find wherever you listen to great
podcasts from the ramsay network
okay i gotta talk about something gotta
get something off of my chest so i'm a
millennial and so i keep up with the
the burgeoning social media trends that
are out there and one of those is tick
tock i do it for you guys so that i know
what's going on out there so i can fill
you all in
and there's a lot of
how do i say this
financial gurus out there
um who can't grow facial hair yet and
they are giving some terrible financial
advice
that truly makes my blood boil and it's
one of the reasons why i want to get in
there i don't want to i don't want to
become a tick-tock star i just have to
get in the middle of the mess and walk
everyone off the ledge because they're
listening to 60 second videos and then
making huge financial decisions because
of it
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to play a video that producer
james found that made my blood boil he
really knows how to push my buttons
we're going to react to it and then
we're going to teach you guys a better
way so let's roll that beautiful bean
footage
when i'm 30 i want to be debt free and
owe no credit cards you know you might
regret that what how well how are you
planning on getting a house or a car
yeah i'm just gonna use all cash by
chance that dave ramsey teach you this
yes why that advice is for people who
are already in debt or don't know how to
manage their money the truth is credit
cards can help build your credit which
is very important and if you pay them
off in full you'll never owe any
interest and with housing prices so high
good credits might be the only way most
people are going to be able to get a
house now that i think about it saving
up 400 000 in cash doesn't sound very
reasonable that advice might work for
some but personal finance should never
be a one-size-fits-all follow to learn
the truth
okay wow that moved so fast i thought i
was having a stroke for a second all
right i don't want to have to watch that
again so let me recap it for you because
he was moving pretty fast
he was saying
that it is unwise to save up 400 000
cash
to get a house and that our advice is
terrible and on top of that that you
need to be building your credit score
you need to be open to that credit card
going into debt staying in debt paying
it off all perfectly so that you can
build that beautiful fico score
i'm here to tell you that uh he
ended it with
learn the truth follow to learn the
truth
and the truth is that that is a lie
and here's why i know it's a lie because
i have purchased a house without a
credit score and i didn't save up four
hundred thousand dollars cash to do it
and what he's doing is he's playing into
the fomo that a lot of young people feel
out there
where they go man the dave ramsey guy he
wants us to save up and pay cash for a
house that's insane that'll take me 38
years
why wouldn't i just put zero down and
get in on this and then i'll get more
real estate and i can leverage more debt
but also i have a car payment i have
student loans
i've got medical bills
and then life crushes you and you go
well
that advice sounded good in theory but
in reality i want to have financial
peace
and so here's let me tell you our actual
advice when it comes to housing just to
make things clear
yes we don't want you to have any debt
at all the only type of debt that we
won't yell at you for is a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage where you can put 10
to 20 percent down and the payment ends
up being no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay
that's exactly what i did me and my wife
in fact we put more than 20 percent down
because we didn't want to be in debt any
longer than we had to and so we
sacrificed we did side jobs we hustled
for a long period of time in order to
put that much down and then we ended up
paying off the house in 26 months and we
did our debt free scream just a few
months back and it was incredible
on top of that when we got the mortgage
we did not have a credit score because
we had paid off our debt long ago and
that leaves your credit score
indeterminable
and so you've all heard that you want to
have you know 750 800 850 perfect credit
score in order to go into debt that's
all it is it's an i love debt course
playing kissy face with the bank
and too many young people are learning
this and guess who they're learning it
from
their parents
when they turn 18 the parents go you got
to open a credit card and they go why
well you got to have the credit score
well why so you can get a car loan so
you can get a massive mortgage with
nothing down
here's what a credit score is made up of
35 debt history 30
current debt level 15
how long you've been in debt 10
and a new debt 10
type of debt are you hearing a theme
debt that's right
so
you don't need a credit score to buy a
car because we're gonna pay cash for
cars
i've done it multiple times it's amazing
they'll actually take your money
you don't need to use credit cards to
build your score because we're paying
cash for things with our debit card and
we're budgeting
you don't need it to rent a car and i
can tell you that because i've done it
multiple times sometimes they'll just
add a buffer maybe let's say 20 of your
total will be added as a deposit on your
checking account temporarily
you don't need it to rent a house or an
apartment
and i've called all over the country we
did this on the fine print on our credit
score episode and almost every single
one said oh i mean that's fine if you
don't have a score now a low score will
hurt you but no score that's fine you
just might need to pay an extra you know
first month last month an extra deposit
that's it
and then finally the big one you don't
need it to buy a house
and our friends at churchill mortgage do
this every day it's called manual
underwriting or a no score loan and they
do it like they did back in the old days
where they just look at your actual
financial picture they look at pay stubs
your w2s do you pay your utility bills
that kind of thing
and they go okay well based on your
situation we're happy to give you a loan
because we know you're gonna pay it back
and so that's what we did
and most people are shocked by this we
did i did a media hit for a new station
over in chicago and they were just
flabbergasted that someone could even
buy a house without a credit score and
so we need to start dispelling these
myths and parents you got to stop
telling your kids this and tick talkers
you got to stop spreading this
misinformation because that video has
millions of views
and the comments are all very thankful
and they're all going yeah that dave
ramsey guy man what a scam artist
because he tells you to get out of debt
and stay out of debt because he wants
you to build wealth and have financial
peace
so
tick-tock at your own risk i'm not
telling you to go there i'm just telling
you
if you want some entertainment or you
want to get angry it's a fun place to be
all right let's move on to joey in san
antonio texas joey welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can i help
uh so i've had a uh really good
six to nine months financially for me
and what it's done is it jumped me ahead
to babysit four awesome uh
i'm starting you know investing for
retirement and really looking into it
and i have an ira roth ira and a current
401k that my company opened when i
started there
and my question to you is
should i be investing in the 401k if my
company doesn't do any match or should i
be starting with the roth ira first and
then secondly
secondly because it was auto open and
i've already got 9k in there
should i be keeping it in there or is
there something i can do with that since
it's you know to
better serve myself if i'm not going to
be matching it this is a traditional
401k not a roth 401k
yeah it's a regular 401k and a roth ira
that i have do they have a roth 401k
option
they don't
okay
well our methodology is we move from
roth
no we move from the match to roth to
traditional so match beats roth beats
traditional so if you have a zero match
we're gonna move to the roth options
first that will grow for us tax-free so
yes i would be fully funding the roth
ira up to up to the total what's your
income
uh
45 to
60. okay so let's go on the high end
let's say 60 000. that's gonna be nine
thousand dollars a year so if you fully
fund the roth ira let's say six thousand
dollars that leaves three thousand that
we're gonna go back to that traditional
401k and put over there
okay
and that's how i do it i would leave the
9000 in there uh we don't tell you to
roll that to the roth until you're at
baby step 7 with a paid for house
because we have bigger financial goals
and you're going to have a tax hit when
you try to move that to a roth account
from traditional
okay
and then
if if you're okay with it i've got one
more question
uh saving up for a car should i just be
putting that in a savings account or
should i be doing something smarter with
that if i'm looking at a year or two
away
a year or two away is not enough of a
timeline to be investing i would just
put it in a sinking fund and a good
savings account money market account
high-yield savings account i know it's
hilarious because it's like a half
percent not quite high yield but stay
the course don't put it in anything
volatile put it somewhere liquid where
you have access to it a year from now
without any issues thanks for the call
man appreciate it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell and i
am your host today
listen people are craving connection
they're craving community and they're
craving the energy that only comes from
humans being with other humans we hear
you and we need it too and that is why
we're bringing back our life-changing
events back on the road and we are not
holding back this year first up we've
got building wealth live and we are
coming to orlando on thursday may 19th
this event is selling super fast so if
you're waiting around to buy your ticket
don't do that because it's going to sell
out this event is going on tour this
year and we're going to have more
locations to share with you guys really
soon we're also bringing our largest
event of the year to dallas texas on
october 22nd that's right smart
conference is back we're gonna have all
of our personalities there myself rachel
cruz dr john delony ken coleman dave
ramsey christina ellis pedro lattore and
our good friends craig and amy grishell
from lifechurch will be there as well
talking about marriage you do not want
to miss this
if you've never been to a ramsay event
or you want to get someone in your life
on board with the ramsey plan this is
the best way to get them dunked and
indoctrinated here we got we're hitting
every single topic not just money we're
talking about career relationships
mental health if you want to learn more
about all of the events that we're
planning this year go to
ramseysolutions.com
events
open phone lines this hour the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five sarah is joining us in
harrisburg pennsylvania sarah welcome to
the ramsay show
hi george um
i'm in baby step two and i'm on my last
thirteen thousand
but we got a bit of a curve ball and now
we have a student loan that's in
collection that has reared its ugly head
and my question is
what do i need to do in order to
negotiate some kind of settlement
because i don't want to do
month-to-month payments with a
collection agency so you want to be
painful with a lump sum ideally
yes how old is this debt
well
my husband had paid on i think for a
couple of years doing month to month out
of his
bank account we got married i said we
can't do that
so it's been over a year since it had
transferred collection agencies we
haven't touched it so you haven't made a
payment in over a year
yeah how did it end up in collections
were you just not able to make the
payments anymore
i'm assuming that's what happened yes
probably that's your husband's
correct
how much is the
current balance
i believe it's between fifty five
hundred and seven thousand somewhere
around there okay i guess would be about
six thousand and is that included in
your thirteen thousand for baby step two
no because i that's what 13 000 is our
active debt so it's a small student loan
in a car loan okay how much cash do you
guys have on hand between
all your savings
if i were to include my
emergency fund four thousand
four thousand bucks three thousand seven
yeah four thousand bucks if i really
needed to max it but i would like to
just use three thousand of it if
possible what's the margin right now if
you guys tighten it up and you stop
eating out you cut all the expenses you
work extra how much margin could you
create each month
well on debt i was paying off about 2500
to 3 000 on debt
every month so i could pause yes i could
pause
and switch it over to
this bad debt
snowball if you will have you talked to
the the collection agency
i was going to call them today
but i didn't want to call them because
you know sometimes you get frustrated
and i just am seeking guidance how to
one be calm on the phone with them yeah
and just some
guidelines or tips to on how to
prepare myself and negotiate with them
because they lie i just don't wanna yeah
well number one i want you to confirm
confirm this debt in writing they have
to legally do that they have to confirm
every single little detail otherwise it
can get thrown out and so that's step
number one is actually confirm the age
the amount of the debt and make sure
they have the authority to actually
collect on this debt
so you can formally request that from
the debt collector when you call them
and you can also make sure this is big
do not give them access to your checking
account when you talk to them say hey
listen
here's how much i can do and you know if
that's the if that's the real balance
you get the letter in writing in the
mail
or emailed then say hey listen i know
the debt is seven thousand
what would you guys willing what would
you be willing to take if i was able to
give you a lump sum today
and if they say 3 000 bucks would do it
i'm writing them that check today
but i should get that in writing before
i get it because like you said they can
tell you one thing on the phone and they
go nope you still owe some more money
and you go no no the guy on the phone
said and so you've got to have this in
writing before we make any decisions
when it comes to negotiating
okay
and once you do that
we're moving on to the other debts that
you've been making the minimum payments
on but i like the idea of doing it a
lump sum getting a deal on paying off
this debt but at the end of the day
this is the debt and if they say no
we're not willing to negotiate and they
or just keep fighting you on it then
you're gonna have to pay up
but i would get that thing out of your
life you do not want those collectors
they're relentless they're never gonna
stop so the best thing you can do is be
proactive and call them more than they
call you
to where they want you out of their life
it's called twice yeah they call them
our in-laws and i was like oh geez
yeah that's not a fun thing to deal with
i hate that you guys are going through
that but i would try to negotiate i mean
usually they're gonna take they'll take
half of what the debt is especially if
it's years old if this was three months
ago you'd have a harder time
but you think because it's been at least
a year almost i think no the more time
that goes by the less likely they feel
like they're going to get any money and
so they're going to take what they can
get at that point and let them know hey
listen this is the money i have to my
name you can either take this or it's
going to be a long time before you're
going to get your money back
so i want to confirm that i guess just
to recap i'd want to confirm the debt
the age the amount
whether they actually have the ability
to do it whether it's input um whether
it's email or
hard copy mail to me
um no access to bank
information or personal information like
that
um and then if they are willing to
negotiate an amount whether that's an
email or a hard copy letter to myself
then
how is the best way to pay them a
personal check or something like for my
bank
or their cashier's check yeah a
cashier's check would do fine um i just
would not just give them blind access to
your checking account
through you know your routing and
routing number and checking account
number and all that
okay
sound good
and then you're going to continue on you
won't have much debt at that point
what's your total income
uh total income
um 160 000
this debt this whole thing is going to
be gone in a few months
yeah i'm looking forward to it we were
at 120 000 a couple years ago and now
we're at the um
their tail
at the end of this tunnel yeah i'm
feeling a lot better so i
was very lucky right before i got
engaged like right after i got engaged i
started doing the guys program and
six months into my marriage i became
debt-free and then kind of just put her
on the back burner when i got married
but
i just said to management let's get this
done we're too young we make too much
money let's just get her done
and i'm just so thankful for it because
we are this close and
this is real now so
that's amazing
that's so great to hear so is your
husband on board with this plan
yes he just wanted me to um
call i guess because he he was quick to
get a little bit more temperamental than
i am oh so he delegated this to you
because he was like i'm not going to say
anything nice to these people
yeah he was afraid he'd get that out of
shape and i told him i i will take the
big step back and i'll get all the
information that we need now stay calm
cool and collected it'll be fine it will
be fine i think he just
worries about that kind of stuff yeah
well hey give us a call back when you're
dead free sarah i'm excited for you guys
thank you i really appreciate it george
yeah stay the course thank you so much
for the call
folks listen if you are
where sarah's at and you you feel that
feeling in your chest where you almost
can't breathe because you have this debt
looming in your life
i want you to have a vision be on friday
because you're living paycheck to
paycheck i want you to have a vision for
your life where you sit down with your
spouse and go we don't have to live like
this
we can get this debt out of our life we
can stay out of debt we can make a plan
for the future we can build wealth and
we can have financial peace
that's what the whole plan is about
this is a get rich slow scheme and it
works every time you work it but you
have to make a decision and go we've got
to do something different we've got to
become a different person than we are
today and when you do that man that is
the first step to freedom this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast and i'll be your host
today on the ramsay show so give us a
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five whatever's on your mind
whatever's freaking you out whatever
you're excited about i love to talk with
you celebrate with you guide you through
whatever is going on in your life
stephen has decided to join us he's in
cleveland ohio stephen welcome to the
show
hi
so i'll get right to it
currently i'm 26 years old i'm debt free
except for my house i'm currently making
70k a year and contributing 15 to my raw
401k
i'm engaged set to be married in october
my fiance is currently in school getting
a master's she's going to graduate about
120k in student loans
i've been paying her housing and living
expenses for the last two years so i'm a
little
house poor i guess you can say
as we get closer to this wedding october
i'm a little worried about having the
funds ready for a wedding at hymen and i
guess i'm wondering if it's okay to back
off or stop
retirement savings to have the extra
cash for the way hmm
so you've been paying her housing bills
for how long
yes uh just under two years now
why
i didn't want her to end up taking more
in student loans
man well that is a it's a bold move for
sure a strange one to be paying
someone's housing bills that you're not
married to
what happens if you if it doesn't work
out would you have any resentment
for paying all the bills we've been
together for eight years now so i guess
i'm you know we're pretty confident okay
well i'll focus on your question here
about how to pay for this wedding is it
all on you guys to pay have you guys had
the conversations with family
yeah so like right now i probably am
maybe like seven or eight short of my
goal and if i was to pause retirement
i'd i'm pretty sure i'd be there by the
time the wedding comes yeah i mean i'm
okay
saving for something like this and
pausing retirement for a short period of
time especially how old are you
i'm 26 you're 26 so you're gonna be okay
pausing this thing for a few months to
make sure that we're set for the wedding
uh do you guys have a wedding budget
currently
uh yeah okay how much is the total
uh the total is right around 30k we got
10 from her parents and i got the rest
okay so 20k is on you and you have how
much save right now
uh just under
14.
okay so you only have six to go then
could you continue to invest and still
have the margin
to save up and pay for this
uh it doesn't look like it i've been
i've been trying to see what else we
could cut back on and is she working it
seems like he's in school no she's not
is she able to
uh no she's going for a med school thing
and she's not allowed to work per
program
well this is a it's a tough situation
because i don't like the idea of you
continuing to pay your housing bills
even until the wedding
and i don't really want you to pause
investing i'm okay with it because i
don't want you to go in debt for the
wedding so if this is the only other
option then this is where we're at
how much longer is she going to be in
med school
she graduates in august so only like
four or five more months okay and then
she'll have income
okay
well here my wedding parameters are this
don't ever spend more than you have in
cash regardless of who's paying for it
and there is no ramsey parameter for
wedding spending but my personal
parameter would be not to spend more
than a third of your gross income if
you're paying for it yourself so in your
case you're putting 20 grand in
and you make 70. so you're not
outrageous there and you've already had
the conversations do you have a checking
account that is just for the wedding
budget
yes okay great and you have exactly what
you need in that wedding budget and
you're not going to go over
yeah okay yeah i feel good about this
plan then i don't love it it's not my
favorite plan but if this is where
you're at and you're getting married and
you said october
and it's currently march so we've got
time but i would try to work extra and
try to save so that you don't have to
pause retirement or you can get back to
it real quick i would try to hunker down
get this money saved up keep it aside in
that savings account for the wedding and
then continue investing
okay yeah i guess one other question
with that is i do have a motorcycle
that's paid for that's worth about 10k i
mean i could easily sell that and
probably be clear for the wedding i love
that plan are you willing to sell it is
it gonna hurt you emotionally
a little bit but but you have another
vehicle
i do yeah i got two other vehicles
actually
oh wow you've two other vehicles
yep you just love things with motors
don't you
i do what is the value of all those add
up to
all the vehicles you have anything with
a motor in it
probably right around 50k yeah that's
too much vehicle when you're making 70.
we say no more than 50
should be tied up and things with motors
in it so yes i'm selling that motorcycle
and congratulations you now have a
wedding fund and you get to keep
investing
gotcha
that hurt didn't it i can feel it in
your voice you didn't want to hear that
but hey you brought it up man i didn't
know you had a motorcycle you were
keeping secrets from me i didn't know we
had options there's more there's more
motorcycles in the world
exactly and once you get rid of her debt
i would you know what i would do
once you guys become debt free you pay
off that 120 000 in student loans make
it a gift to yourself to save up and get
yourself a motorcycle
if she's okay with it i mean you know
i'm i'm too scared i won't even ride on
the back one of those things behind
james our producer
but you're a brave man cool congrats on
the wedding can i give you a gift
uh sure okay i'm gonna send you uh one
year membership to ramsay plus and i
want you and your fiance to go through
all the financial peace university
videos get on an every dollar budget you
can make a separate one for the wedding
and have one for your life once you
combine your incomes once you're married
but you can go through the videos now
and get on the same page and start to
make a plan for how we're going to pay
off these student loans
sounds lovely awesome i'll have austin
pick up and he will get you that ramsay
plus membership thanks for the call
congrats on the impending marriage all
right let's move on to john in l.a john
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you doing boss great i like that
you call me boss i appreciate that
usually it's dave's products
uh i'll make it i'm gonna be quick and
simple i know you guys have a lot of
people you guys help out and thank you
for everything you guys do uh my
question is uh i'm 24 i still live at
home with my family
and
i live by the dave ramsey principles
i live it like it's religiously and
my family is not on the same plan as me
they live by old principles and they
don't do any research when it comes to
buying a house or really any research
they just go off their own basic
knowledge which i don't believe in and
it's creating a lot of friction in the
home
between us we're finding ourselves
arguing and debating a lot when it comes
to about finances
and i'm just trying to figure out is it
time to just move out and go on my own
are you working
yes what's your income
about 70k
awesome what do you do for work
uh i'm a security manager i manage at
different companies
now making 70k can you rent somewhere
near you
near work um
i can uh it's just going to take my rent
from approximately less than five
hundred dollars to well over you know
sixteen to two thousand dollars unless i
uh even if i went and bought a house at
the same time
well i'm moving out if i'm you and i
know it's a crazy area over there very
expensive but here's the parameters i
would give you as you're looking try to
keep the payment under 25
of your take-home pay
and if that's difficult it may mean
getting a roommate for now
so that you can afford it but living
with your parents in what you would
probably describe as kind of a toxic
environment i don't want that for you
guys you can maintain this relationship
and go listen i love you and i disagree
with you and that's okay but i don't
want to have these disagreements every
day at dinner
and so you're 24 you make a great income
i think it's time to fly the coop
okay the another issue is i am on the
lease
to the home
that we're renting so
they
they are throwing it in my face that i'm
going to leave them high and dry to take
care of my portion
of the rent
and it's kind of making me feel bad
but it's kind of hard to feel bad when
they order doordash and food and go to
restaurants um but then complain that
i'm the reason why they want this might
be the kick in the pants they need so
i'm gonna try to get out of this lace
legally and respectfully and tell mom
and dad i love you but you guys need to
figure out your financial situation too
and you're dragging each other down to
this point so i think it's time to get
out man and i know that's gonna be
easier said than done but uh i believe
in you you got this appreciate the call
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast all of which you can
find on the ramsey network
open phones this hour the phone number
to call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five david is kicking us
off in tulsa oklahoma david welcome to
the ramsay show
hey george good afternoon thank you for
taking my call absolutely how can i help
well we just came into just a little bit
of money uh recently and i'd say a
little bit more about nine thousand
and we are looking at
would it be wise to invest the nine
thousand uh straight into the principle
of our house um we currently have a
mortgage with 120 000
outside of the mortgage we are debt-free
and
looking at if we should do that or
invest into maybe a roth ira
or maintain the funds within a savings
account
reason i'm being cautious about it is
we've got one vehicle with roughly 120
000 miles on it
and the second one is about 250 000
miles
both of them kind of have their issues
and as well as maintenance and stuff but
um we're just kind of looking at how we
can keep this down um
we haven't been invested we're at the i
guess baby step three
and we haven't been putting the max
towards our retirement
as as we as we could um
mainly because it kind of puts us in a
crunch financially
so every month i would think so it
sounds like you're doing multiple baby
steps at
once you said you're investing but you
don't have the emergency fund in place
right right we have the emergency fund
in place uh so our estimated emergency
fund be about fourteen thousand
um for for six months we do look pretty
tight um but we also have a savings
of about 40 000 right now
what's that for
just sitting in the bank uh just it's
just sitting in the bank and that's why
i haven't been
um you know investing that in a roth or
anything like that like i think that's
probably the next step we need to take
hold on so you said you're in baby step
three but you're telling me you have a
fully funded emergency fund
i have a fully funded emergency fund yes
so your baby step four thousand dollars
okay
we did the thousand dollars we paid off
all of our debts uh no school loans
anything like that um no car loans
no car loans okay we just simply have
our mortgage at 120. okay and you're not
quite investing 15
of your gross income into retirement
correct we're about at 8 right now
how come
do you not have the money mainly
so my right i make about 60 000 a year
and my wife had recently
kind of stepped away for
maternity leave so that really kind of
impacts our finances a little bit there
and
i just i like having that comfort of
having in the bank i guess where i
really should be just investing it to
the max
um
but mainly the cars have me a little bit
paranoid um in what we should do there
because i know we've got two children um
both very young and it concerns me you
know maybe getting out on the road and
then something breaking down sure um
so it sounds like that's mine we gotta
focus on on one thing at a time and
right now we can't invest the 15 because
it's tough you also have these cars over
here that are on their way out and so we
tell people to have syncing funds you
know your car breaking down when it has
250 000 miles that's not really an
emergency because you can kind of see
that one coming from a mile away
so what i would do if i'm you guys
you're saying you have 40 000 in savings
on top of the 14 000 emergency fund and
you have 9 000 that just showed up
uh no sir let me correct that so we have
40 000 total and
within that before yeah okay well i'm
gonna set aside some of that 40 to get
these cars upgraded
so i'd be selling those if maybe the 250
one for now sell that one and get
something reasonable
okay
i would get something as cheap as
possible that gets the job done this is
a to b this is not us trying to look
flashy because like you said you don't
have enough margin to even be doing baby
step four let alone paying down the
house so we have some we got an issue
here with our budget our expenses our
income that we've got to take care of
so i would probably look for a ten
thousand dollar car you know not quite a
beater but not quite something that's
going to turn heads at the stoplight
okay
okay and beyond that i want you to get
to that 15 if that means fully funding a
roth ira for this year with some of that
money i'm okay with that
but we have to figure out long-term
solution for this and i don't want you
just sitting on a pile of money because
it makes you feel good i want it working
for you and that means continuing on
with the baby steps saving for college
paying off the house early and you and
your wife should have a talk about what
that looks like
beyond maternity leave is she going back
to work is she gonna stay home
yeah no she's she's actually started
back up now um so before before the
maternity leave she would be working on
the weekends um
not full time should be staying at home
at home with the kids we've not really
looked at pricing out
um any kind of daycare or you know
babysitting currency what percentage is
the mortgage taking up of your take-home
pay
um
we're right at
just under a grand as far as the
mortgage and what's your take-home pay
60 grand
your take-home pay 60
i'm sorry no that's my gross okay so
it's probably closer to four grand a
month
that ends up in your bank account right
okay so the mortgage isn't killing you
guys i'm just trying to find out where
all the money's going because generally
when people pay off debt and they have
an emergency fund they they can find the
room to invest that 15 without a
crushing them and i know you guys you
have kids there's some crazy expenses
inflation it's a strange time right now
so i don't want to define your life by
these numbers
but we need to look at how can we can
trim expenses i would go down a budget
audit go through every insurance premium
you have i'd be shopping around through
xander to see if we're if we can get a
better deal elsewhere i'm going to look
at how much we're eating out i'm going
to tighten it up are you guys on a
written plan and tracking it every month
we were following it pretty good um
lately it has kind of stepped away we
kind of enjoyed our getting out just a
little bit from being tied in with all
the code and everything so i would think
we'd probably spend maybe 30 bucks uh
maybe every two weeks on eating out so
we'll just kind of stop it and get a
little lunch somewhere
yeah well i can hear the kids in the
background it's they seem real sweet
but i would try you gotta that's the
only way to create that margin is we're
gonna trim expenses and we're gonna
bring in more income and so figure out
what that looks like
this money needs to be put to use i
would upgrade one of the cars for now
and
if the emergency hits where the other
one goes out that's what the emergency
fund is for but i would create a sinking
fund where you can put aside some extra
car savings money through your cash flow
income
and try to get to that 15 as soon as you
can
yeah one thing we were looking at is
with the valuation of cars so like as
far as her
her vehicle it's the one with the 250
but the body everything
seems great on it um outside of the you
know
engine and transmission
uh not really had any issue yet but you
just know it's coming yeah so my thought
and recently my father had had a newer
engine placed in his uh tundra
and when that happened i mean it's just
like as long as i found a brand new car
again yeah so i kind of looked at that a
little bit because then we're not going
to be out investing to bring you know a
like new car sure well i would i would
not go putting a new engine in that car
i would just go ahead and get something
used you guys have the money to do it
it's not worth messing with this thing
anymore get rid of it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print podcast
well folks if you drive a normal car
like normal people you've had to get gas
like normal people and you've probably
been very angry at the pump
here in our neck of the woods gas is
running about
four dollars and 30 cents right now
which is about double what it was it
feels like six months ago
and to add insult to injury
the buy now pay later companies are
screwing everyone over because here's
the new news out this week you can now
buy now pay later
for gas that's right you can now have
the pleasure of paying for gas that you
bought three weeks ago
this is sad stuff and uh klarna and zip
they have partnered with gas stations to
provide this texaco and chevron gas
stations have the option to split up
your payment into four payments over six
weeks
so we like to joke that you can do buy
now pay later on a ten dollar item and
make 2.50
payments for four months
and now you can do that with a gallon of
gas or 10 gallons of gas
and we just released our ramsey research
state of personal finance annual report
and by now pay later has exploded in
popularity especially with the younger
generations nearly one in four people
made a purchase using a buy now pay
later service in 2021 and millennials
are leading the charge four in ten
millennials made an online purchase with
buy now pay later compared to just 18
percent of gen x and just four percent
of baby boomers and if you know anything
about buying out pay later it's just a
modern marketing version of installment
plans
so when you go add to cart right below
that it looks like you can get 75 off by
splitting it up into four payments
and the companies are making a lot of
money on this the retailers are making
so much money on this and it's not just
the interest and fees they can get you
with the bigger issue i have with it is
the overspending
in fact klarna on their website they are
bragging to retailers that customers
spend 45
more on the average store order when
they use a buy now pay later service
so at least they're self-aware that
they're screwing you
i guess that's a good sign
don't do this don't pay for gas that you
bought three weeks ago
when you are paying for the past you
can't build for the future
so i know times are tough i know gas is
insane i know housing is insane i know
car prices are insane
so here what can we do about this well
we can control the controllables and we
can still pay cash for things and it
might mean more patience it might mean
more sacrifice it might mean we're
cutting a subscription we're not eating
out as much we're meal prepping we're
eating at a new restaurant called mikasa
that's right we're going to eat at our
house if you don't know basic spanish
101 there
so this is sad to see and i want you
guys to stay away from the buy now pay
later schemes i want you to delay your
purchases be a y spender stick to your
budget and if you want to learn more
about buy now pay later we did an entire
episode on this on season one of the
fine print you can find that wherever
you listen to podcasts and it's called
after pay affirm klarna should you buy
now or pay later you can go check that
out wherever you listen to podcasts
all right let's go to the phones this
hour you can call us at
825-5225
anna joins us in nyc anna welcome to the
show
hi um how are you good how are you
um i'm good i'm in a bit of a sticky
situation
so i have
180 000
worth of student loans
and that's undergrad and grad loans
together
and so they're comprised of a few
different ones with different
percent interests and as of may 1st i'm
supposed to start paying them back
and i recently started working
making about a hundred thousand per year
that's come from and i'm not
yeah so i'm not renting yet but i'm also
moving out of my family's house which
i've been living at since colvin
so that's going to be
an expense
added on as well and i'm just very lost
in how to
handle these loans i'm not sure if i
should refinance or consolidate or do
income based repayment
um so i was hoping to get your advice on
that yeah well at the end of the day
there's only one way to get rid of debt
and that's to get rid of debt and so i
don't like consolidation and refinance
as a shortcut because it's not a
shortcut you're just moving the debt
around and feeling like you did
something and so the best thing you can
do
is use the debt snowball method to
attack these debts are you familiar with
that
um a little bit
so um i think you you tackle
this uh i forgot if it was the smallest
or the largest loan the smallest so
here's what you're gonna do okay you're
gonna ignore the interest rate i know
that hurts because you're a smart woman
and you go you look at the interest rate
and it makes you want to throw up right
yeah it's about six percent right now
which is terrifying and
i'm i was hoping to get that down to
four percent which a lot of these
refinancing companies offer but i don't
know if that's the way to go
well i mean it's worth a shot if you
want to look at that our friends at
splash financial they're they're good
people and you can check with them to
see what you could do i don't mind it
when you can lower the interest rate i
just don't want you to extend the length
of the loan
so sometimes what they'll do is they'll
go yeah we'll give you four percent but
now you're in debt even longer and your
your payments higher and so there's all
kinds of things they can do to kind of
trick you into thinking that you got a
deal
so i would check with splash but really
at the end of the day i still want you
to do the dead snowball i don't want you
to consolidate this because what happens
is it becomes one giant mountain and
it's unbearable
versus feeling the progress freeing up
each payment as you pay it off so what i
would do is you can use the debt
snowball calculator on our website
and you can actually put in all of your
debts from smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate just
ignore that and we're gonna start paying
off the smallest one with a vengeance so
make minimum payments on all of the
other student loans you can afford to do
that right come may first
um yeah i i will i don't know what what
the payment would be
um if i
because uh there's a lot of individual
loans there's actually about like 23. to
be exact
yeah well the good news is they're
probably all fairly small especially at
the front end yeah yeah yeah there's
there's a few really huge ones and then
there's a bunch that are about a
thousand or a thousand five hundred yeah
now when you move out are you going to
get a roommate
yeah so i already signed a lease
actually for may 1st as well um and my
expense there will be about 1500 which
i'm sure sounds crazy but it's new york
so it's kind of standard
so i don't know even how much
i
could be paying off
while also you know
living in new york city as well and and
i'm not like a big fender by any means
i'm ready to just like
eat rice and beans for a while and
you're gonna continue living like a
broke college student because you're
broke right now thanks to these student
loans
now what kind of work are you doing
i'm a software engineer oh awesome
well yeah hopefully your income will
continue to go up
yeah it's my first software engineering
job so
i'm hoping it'll obviously only go up
from here is it remote or is it in the
office
it's hybrid so it's two days remote
three days in the office okay well i
know in the software engineer world in
that tech world you can leapfrog when it
comes to income when you move to this
company and that company and all of a
sudden you could be making two three
hundred thousand in that world
right that's definitely the goal so use
that to your advantage as you start this
kind of new chapter with a roommate live
like you're broke and if you can do that
i mean the 1500 a month is going to eat
up a good chunk of your income but
beyond that if you can throw you know 60
70k of debt at the debt you can be done
with this thing i want you to be done in
two years anything beyond that i'm going
this is just two years this is too long
that's 90 000 a year obviously it's not
possible with your current income and
current living situation but let's say
you worked fully remote and you could
move somewhere less expensive or move
you know across the bay or whatever that
looks like for you
and you hustled and you did some side
hustling with your software engineer
skills you brought in an extra 20k these
are the kind of sacrifices that you're
going to have to make if you want to
climb out of this hole and you don't
want it to be a slog of seven years and
you're still trying to pay off these
student loans and you're still trying to
mess around with consolidation to fix
the problem we gotta rip the band-aid
off and look at the hard numbers but i'm
telling you the debt snowball is your
best path to do it you're going to feel
the progress you're going to free up
payments along the way and you're going
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel hang on and i'm going to have
kelly give you ramsey plus one year
membership to help walk with you along
this journey and you call us back if we
can do anything else to help you thanks
for calling
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call haley joins us now in destin
florida haley welcome to the show
hello
hey how you doing how can i help
um okay so
my question is my husband and i have
about sixty thousand dollars in debt um
and
because of covid we i'm sure you hear
that all the time we had to repossess
out voluntarily repossess our camper
and then you know how that goes we have
we owe 23 000 now and don't even have
the camper
and also i have a car that we are ten
thousand dollars
with upside down negative equity
um so
we have random credit cards we are on
step two trying to do the debt snowball
um
and we we're renting right now and
that's been forwarded over twenty three
hundred dollars a month
um
yeah so what's your income
um i personally make about 65 000 and my
husband we're
we're not really sure maybe 20 35 and he
owns his own landscaping company
it doesn't sound like it's doing too hot
if he's making 20 grand
no he he works by himself um
so i mean he i think it's more than that
honestly this is only his second year
we haven't done our taxes yet to really
show how much he's making
hold on you don't know how much you're
making
he shouldn't be running a business if he
doesn't know how much money he makes
well quickbooks says he's making a lot
but we're not really we're learning
um
so yeah well that's a tough time to
learn when you've got all this debt
sitting around but that's a story for
another day so let's say you're making
what 95k
a year yeah and you got 60k in debt and
we're underwatering a few things here so
how can i help today exactly
what should we
what is your suggestion like we like i
said um we haven't actually paid on the
camper in over a year
because my credit is shot so i was just
like whatever but we eventually want to
have kids we eventually want to buy a
house so we don't have to be paying the
2 300 a month
so i guess like what do we just continue
to do that snowball like do you have any
advice on repossessions i guess how much
money do you guys have to your name
right now that's liquid
like um
fifteen hundred dollars right now we
have but we pretty much live paycheck to
paycheck
well you've got your baby step one if
you set aside a thousand dollars and
then we're gonna go to town and this
dude better be mowing so many lawns that
you forget what he looks like
yeah yeah he's got it he's gotta get
this
he was hospitalized with brad though
because he wasn't oh my goodness well he
needs to charge more or something
something about this business isn't
working out but aside from that we want
you to do the debt snowball in baby step
two so i would list all of these out
small is the largest if you're ten
thousand underwater on this car how much
is left on the loan
i'm 23 000.
and you're saying the car is only worth
13.
yeah are you sure 13
13 to 17 000. yeah we um
what happened was i had a car and then i
had a warranty call me and said that my
car warranty was up and i fell for it
and had to pay 200 extra a month it was
a scam and then it was a scam you were
the one who fell for that that call
where they say hey i'm calling about
your car's extended warranty
i know and i cried actually when i went
to the car dealer and he was like the
only way to get rid of this warranty
because they couldn't find it
is to trade in the car so then i got
sold by a car dealer
turn all phones and screens off don't
listen to anyone don't talk to anyone
just work your butt off i don't pay off
this debt
well i mean 10 10 to 17 13 to 17 is a
big range i'm gonna go and do some
really good research i'm going to check
with carvana and vroom and dealerships
and facebook marketplace and see what
this car is actually worth go to
kellybluebook.com
all those sites do some really good
research to see what you could get for
this car because
if you can get 17 18 000 and you owe 23
the only time i would tell you to uh go
get a loan is when you're underwater on
this car and you go to your local credit
union and you get a small five thousand
dollar personal loan to get out from
underneath this car
now that's not a shortcut it's not a
life hack but what it does is speed up
this process and create a five thousand
dollar loan instead of a twenty three
thousand dollar loan today
yeah do you need that vehicle do you
have other vehicles
um
my husband has a paid off truck but yes
i will i would need a car and it is a
hybrid so it's saving me money a lot of
money on gas and i live less than two
miles from work
so i don't really need a that helps
scooter i mean you guys could keep the
car and pay it all off you if you're
making 100 and you got 60 in debt we can
be done with this thing in under two
years so it's reasonable yeah
but yeah i i feel like you're so
overwhelmed right now i mean who cares
if you're saving money on gas when you
can't breathe because you're living
paycheck to paycheck
yeah
yeah
so i'm going to follow the debt snowball
and i'm going to research this car and
figure out if it's worth selling and uh
getting out from this underwater vehicle
so that we can speed up this process but
you're going to list your debts from
smallest to largest we're ignoring the
interest rate we're ignoring phone calls
from scammers we're ignoring everyone
and everything that's in our way all
distractions are gone we're not eating
out because we're broke no no we don't
we don't need that
okay
i want you guys to have a house i want
you guys to have kids and you can have
all those things but right now we have
to pay a price to win and it's not going
to be fun the next year and a half of
your life is going to be brutal but man
it's going to set you free if you do
this stuff
yeah yeah we're christian so we we
believe in that the lord told me it's
gonna be a clear year so like that's
when i'll go okay we need to like put
our boots on the ground and figure this
out boom um so
well haley i appreciate the call we're
cheering you guys on
okay thank you so much absolutely
good stuff all right let's move on to
tanner he's in johnson city tennessee
tanner welcome to the show
hey george thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can i help today
hey i was just calling to see what your
best suggestion is my wife and i are on
baby step six
and we're trying to figure out what's
the best amount to contribute to our hsa
do you guys have a match through work
for that
no not a match to work okay but we do
have a high deductible it's five grand
okay
well i mean you can save up to the
deductible that's what i would do right
now but obviously uh there's gonna be a
max on that uh if if you're both
involved is it are you both on the hsa
yeah so it's next would be seven okay i
would not max it out right now until you
have that paid for house that's when i
go okay now we can have some fun
uh but i would
try to get it to that deductible limit
so that in case you had to hit that
deductible you've got the money in your
hsa to cover it
how much is in there now great
not much couple hundred bucks okay yeah
i mean i i don't think you need there's
no urgency to fully fund this thing asap
but do you guys have the margin to to do
that to contribute each month maybe
yeah definitely on top of paying off the
house early
just yeah we we can we can manage what's
left on the mortgage
um
175.
okay what's your income
so just shy of 100 okay two of us
well that's great man you guys are doing
great and i love that you're using that
hsa as you know the sweet triple tax
benefits of that not being taxed when
you put money in growing tax-free and
not being taxed when you take it out for
medical expenses are you guys both
pretty healthy
yeah yeah we're both in our uh late 20s
so
but just trying to prepare ahead of time
yeah that's wise well i would work to
get that hsa number to your deductible
but i don't think there's any massive
urgency do you have your emergency fund
in place
yeah so worst case we can dip into that
if it goes beyond what's in our hsa but
long term i love having that deductible
amount in there and that's going to give
you a whole other layer of financial
peace and once you pay off that house a
few years from now let's max that thing
out every year and you can start
investing in good growth stock mutual
funds in there and it becomes a really
cool retirement vehicle
and that was my next question about
investing so you guys typically do also
yeah yeah absolutely i would look at
some good growth stock mutual options
that you have inside of that account and
once you have a certain buffer in there
you can begin to invest that money it
may look different depending on your hsa
but absolutely it's a great way to
invest that is tax advantage thanks so
much for the call tanner this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the fine print
if you've been listening to the show for
a little while you probably know about
dr john deloney's new book we're all
super pumped about it it's called own
your past change your future and what
makes it extra cool is that we're
partnering with our friends at
betterhelp to give you a month of free
one-on-one weekly therapy when you
pre-order a copy who does that that's
incredible
you're never too old or too young to
improve your health and make your
relationship stronger and this free
month of one-on-one weekly therapy is
going to help you get the tools that you
need to change your future and what's
cool is you'll get matched up with a
therapist based on your specific needs
this is a life-changing combo dr john
dolone's own your past change your
future it's going to make you laugh it's
going to make you cry it's going to
challenge you and when you take the
steps that he outlines in this book and
you take advantage of that free therapy
your life will be transformed just like
it is when you follow the baby steps
with your money you can do that for your
mental health for your relationships and
for your wellness
get those free therapy sessions by
pre-ordering own your past change your
future today for just 20 bucks at
ramsaysolutions.com
let's go to the phones this hour they
are open you can give us a call at
825-5225 christine joins us in rockford
illinois christine welcome to the show
hi george can you hear me yes you sound
great how can i help
good my boyfriend and i have been
talking about marriage and both see our
relationship ending in marriage soon
we've started looking at how much
weddings cost and are a little
overwhelmed by this we're looking for
some advice on how much is appropriate
to spend on a wedding and how much to
budget for it our finances are both
separate and will remain separate until
we're married i'm in baby step four and
he's in baby step six
awesome well that helps when you're both
debt-free are you guys paying for this
whole wedding or have you talked to your
respective families about it
we'll be paying for it okay
well i
want you to spend as little as possible
for a great day
yeah that looks different for everyone i
know you've you know you've been
dreaming about this day since you were a
little girl probably
that's fair
so the biggest parameter is don't spend
more than you have in cash regardless of
who's paying for it
there is no official parameter but i'll
tell you some stats here according to a
study from wedding wire couples on
average spend roughly 28 000 on the
ceremony and reception which equals
about 215 dollars a guest and with the
average household income being about 55
60 000 that means most people spend on
average half of their annual income on a
wedding which personally i think is just
too much
now what do you guys have in mind for
the wedding
we're looking at spending about forty
thousand dollars oh
do you have a lot of friends
and big family yes oh boy
well i mean remember what you're doing
here you're just throwing a party for
other people at this point
so the question is
when you do the math on 40 000 divided
by how many people are attending look at
that and go
all right is that guy jeff from call is
he worth 200 to me
for him to you know have an open bar and
have a great meal
that's the question you gotta ask
yourself so i don't want you to let
emotion drive these decisions i want you
to remember that this day is about you
two
so cull the invite list before it gets
out of hand
have you already made a budget for this
no we're looking at that now but you're
in your mind you're going 40 grand feels
right
we've kind of broken it down based on
averages in our area ah
well here's the here's the truth what
the whole wedding industry is one giant
scam
and so they can charge because people
are willing to pay for it
so i want you to really take a good look
at this and not get too emotional and
excited about what could be
because those three thousand dollars you
spent on flowers they die
the next day
and the memories will live on
but i would look at the budget and go
okay is do we really need video can we
just do photo do we need the four
thousand dollar wedding photographer or
is the two thousand dollar photographer
gonna do a great job
have you talked to your boyfriend about
this
yes
and when do you think he's gonna propose
uh in the next couple weeks
when do you plan on getting married have
you guys talked about a potential date
probably not until fall of 23 at the
earliest
okay so you've got some time to save up
for this
what is your income
i make about 90 000 a year
okay what does he make and then he makes
about 115 000 years
okay and you guys would both be
splitting this evenly to pay for the
wedding yeah okay
so you're in for 20k he's in for 20k at
this point if we move forward with this
plan
correct and so we need to
look at okay we're going to create a
sinking fund twenty thousand dollars
divided by how many months until we're
gonna have to pay for these expenses
all right that's gonna be you know a
thousand dollars a month does that sound
reasonable to you guys as you talk that
part through
it does
okay
well i mean this is your call there's no
stipulation if you want to spend the
money and you have it i'm good with that
as long as you don't go into debt but
i'm also good with with trimming down
this budget and make sure you have a
separate checking account just for
wedding expenses
get a separate checking uh debit card
for those wedding expenses so that
things don't get too muddy
wonderful thank you so much george
absolutely thanks for the call congrats
on the wedding very exciting
joe is in chicago joe welcome to the
ramsay show
mr campbell thank you so much it is an
honor to talk to you oh you as well
you've got a great voice for radio in
the house oh well thank you very much i
appreciate that
let me give you a little background let
me give you a little background uh i am
in baby step four five and six
um three years ago uh my wife and i were
eighty thousand dollars in debt
and i am proud to say that between
retirement non-retirement we are a
hundred thousand plus wow
yes that's amazing way to go
yes absolutely so my question is um
when i am continuing
this
adventure or journey whatever you want
to call it
um to become wealthy
how do i
continue to stay humble and grounded
hmm that's a great question would you
consider yourself a person that has
humility right now
absolutely
what would make that change let's say i
handed you a hundred thousand dollars
today and a really nice car would it
make you any less humble
i don't think it would make me any less
humble now i really don't so what's the
worry there what's behind us i my my
worry is that money can change people
but
there is one thing in my life that i
know keeps me very grounded
and when she came to me the other night
and she asked me how are we doing we do
the budget together
we do everything together
but
she likes she she lets me take the reins
because i'm the nerd and she's the
dreamer
so
when i came to her and i gave her that
number of a hundred thousand sitting
between those two accounts
that smile is what's going to keep me
humble
i can tell you that right now
well that's the thing there's there's no
amount of money that's gonna make you a
jerk or not we say that money makes you
more of who you already are it's a
magnifying glass and so you don't sound
like a big egotistical narcissistic jerk
who's flashing around his money and if
you had another 100 000 i don't know
that you turn into that guy either now i
do love that you've you want to make
sure you don't end up there because yeah
you're right people can change
people can turn into jerks
but if you're watching out for that
you're not doing things to impress
people i would really check your motive
with every single purchase that you make
with every move you're making you know
are you driving a flashy car to impress
people or do you just love you just love
cars are you getting the mansion to
impress people 400 dodge ram
that 2005 dodge ram is not flashy by no
means so you're not a flashy guy to
begin with
no absolutely not are you a person of
faith
yes i am
i think that's one of the best ways to
to keep me grounded anytime you think
you're something you know dave always
says better than i deserve
because if you believe in the bible
you're a man of faith a christian it's
hard to really think of something
you know even me sitting here hosting
the show there's an entire team of
people that it takes to run this show
there are a thousand things that have to
happen for me to do what i do and so i
don't take it for granted at all that
i'm just so amazing and i get to be in
the seat
and so as long as you keep that mindset
of man i'm so grateful for what i have
i'm so content i'm not making purchases
out of uh need to impress people i just
love my life i've got financial peace
and that's okay and people will think
what they want to think and that's okay
but if you treat people with dignity you
live by the golden rule uh man you're
gonna do just fine you're gonna keep
that humility that we all love so much i
appreciate the code the the call joe
appreciate you uh being debt free giving
us a call
this show is about you america and we're
thankful you're listening that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsay personality george campbell and i
am your host today flying solo they all
ditched me so this is what you got
america and i'm excited to take your
call
whether you need some confirmation
affirmation motivation education if it
ends a nation i'm here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call megan kicks
us off in chicago illinois megan welcome
to the show
okay george can you hear me are you in a
wind tunnel what's happening over there
i am i'm outside if you can't hear me oh
no you sound great you sound great how
can i help okay okay three years ago i
bought an existing business
took out an sba loan for it
um everything was going great and took
over it smashed it
um we were down 90
for most of kovid we're starting to pick
back up
um but
we've found lately it's really hard to
hire people to do what we need them to
do are busy they're independent
contractors so it's more of a side gig
and our busiest time of the day is
monday through friday from about 10 to
3.
so my husband and i are ending up doing
a lot of this work however
we haven't been able to pay ourselves
through this business for about two
years
um okay so then when kovic took that
business out we bought another one in
cash
that business now cash flows about
six to eight thousand dollars a month
great
and
i'm wondering if we should consider
selling
that business putting that money into
the fba loan
and just putting all of our efforts into
the first business
to try to get it back up and running
like it was before
i mean i like this plan so far so you're
saying should we sell the business
that's bringing in zero dollars that we
took out a loan on
no should we sell the business is
bringing in about seven thousand dollars
some more
but that money that we make on that
business into the business of making
sure on ourselves oof
i wouldn't want to sell the business
that's actually profitable
to put it into the one that's making
nothing
you would do that no i mean i don't how
is that a good plan if it's making zero
dollars for you guys right now net
profit well we have a
on the profitable business zero debt on
the
i mean the profitable
the first business it's making money but
it's all going to our debt service the
sba loan
so if you didn't have that loan in your
life what would a cash flow for you guys
net
right now
about 5 000 a month
so that's how much you're putting on the
debt
yeah before clovid it was making about
10.
so we're still at about 50 percent of
what we were at before clovis the first
one sounds like it's a grind i mean do
you even want to continue that business
so when it's up and running
it's minimal effort from myself it's a
great business it's just
right now we've been having a really
hard time finding people to work in it
will that change in the future
what's that will that change in the
future or will it always be
hard to find people
i hope so yeah it requires a
a lot of driving
from our people and so
i think gas pressures right now are
throwing people off but you know maybe
even in the summer we'll get some
college students that can get excited
about doing what we do and they're
paying for their own gas
yeah
yeah that could be a tough sell right
now
yeah so um you know
we've really started to pick up with
this business in the past three weeks
which is great but it's made us do four
to five hours a day of work on top of
you know working at other
business and other jobs
and so we just feel a little bit struck
because that loan is there and we have
to pay it no matter what how much is
left on the loan
two hundred and seventy thousand dollars
whoa
about seven years left i mean how much
could you sell the the business for
well
i mean probably what two and a half of
what we make so about 150 000
which would just cut the debt down but
it wouldn't actually free up any payment
or cash flow right no we'd still be
liable for the rest of it and that's
what worries me is it just feels like
we're not gonna create any more cash
flow and we're gonna lose the 68 the six
to eight thousand a month that we
currently have so my worry is it
actually puts you guys in a worse
position
yeah so
my thought although i i love being at
the business of cash flowing um it is
very hands-on for me
also right now
but if we sold it
we can make
160 000 off of it put that into the
other business reduce that loan and just
put 100 of my time into bringing that
business back up to where it was
before covered then we could start
making a little bit of money and even if
it's a little bit for a while it's
better than nothing well the problem is
there's a lot of ifs in this situation
there's a lot of if this happens and if
this happens then this could happen
and that's the part that i don't like i
want you guys to be in control of
that piece of the future and so right
now it spooks me a little bit to just
sell off the only business that's
bringing in money for your life
yeah because we just don't know even if
you pay down the loan that you're going
to find workers and then you're going to
get this business back up to 10k a month
so i would try to get that business back
up and running before you sell it and so
if you can get this plate spinning over
here where you have workers it's
generating five six seven eight thousand
a month then i think we can go okay we
know that this is working if we went all
in on this we can get this even higher
and we can sell this business and pay
down the debt
okay so i wouldn't go ahead and do that
today but i don't think it's a bad plan
once you get this other business back up
and running
okay i agree
i'm glad we're in agreement i hope your
husband agrees
have you have you talked this over with
him what's he want to do
um
he is
he's under the impression right now they
just have to grind it's just a
just a rough season right now and we
just have to
kind of grit our teeth and get through
it
well he knows how good of the business
this other you know the one with the
loan can't be
how easy it is to run once it's all
running smoothly well as we say business
is easy until people get involved
and you can't even get people involved
right now that's the sad part
yeah so i would i would try to bring the
boat a little closer to the dock before
we go ahead and jump ship here and what
i'm gonna do is is have kelly send you a
copy of dave's best-selling book on
business and leadership called entre
leadership and this is his playbook of
how he built this business from a card
table in his living room to now multi
hundreds of millions of dollars over a
thousand people on the team and he did
it all debt-free
and like you mentioned this would be a
whole different situation if you didn't
take out a quarter of a million dollars
in debt on this business yeah there'd be
no worries on it and so that is why we
tell people to start and run their
businesses debt-free completely from now
until eternity so i'm rooting for you
megan but uh you've got a hole to clean
up here with 270 000 in business debt
and i would not sell my only profitable
business right now to try to get the
other one off the ground that's just too
much risk for me
folks i host the entree leadership
podcast and if you want some business
and leadership inspiration uh go check
that out you can check it out wherever
you listen to podcasts we have some
amazing thought leaders guests on there
a lot of ramsay leaders and really
unpacking what uh the right way to lead
looks like what the right way to run a
business looks like how to lead a team
in a time such as this so go check that
out wherever you listen to podcasts i
salute all of the small business owners
out there you guys are the backbone of
the economy the backbone of america and
we are big big fans of small business
we'll be back with you before you know
it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality and
host of the fine print if you want to
keep up with me you can find me on
instagram at george campbell always love
hearing from you guys answering your
questions over there as well
neil joins us in new brunswick new
jersey neil welcome to the ramsay show
hey george how's it going great how can
i help
yeah so right now i'm 22 years old
making
around 90 take home and i've been
listening to you guys for i think three
or four years now since i was like 18.
awesome so a big fan
and kind of have a small problem going
on in my life
so i do listen with my parents right now
and
i don't pay rent um technically but i do
end up paying you know one to two k you
know putting money into the house uh
like groceries and miscellaneous
expenses um and just wanted to ask you
um i don't
you know like staying at home
and i want to
finance you know a big wedding coming up
uh hopefully when i'm like 25 26
do you think i should kind of
move out or kind of save money and
continue staying at home
i think you should move out based on the
information you just gave me and let me
just be clear you said finance a wedding
that worried me do you mean pay cash
no no i just wanted to kind of save up
for it for a wedding like a bigger
wedding
scott so you're not going into debt for
this wedding
no no okay you worried me never use the
word finance it scares me
you spooked me there because you've been
following us for a few years now so have
you followed the baby steps do you have
any debt
no so um luckily my parents did pay for
my college tuition so no debt just
that's why i'm trying to make the
correct move so i can
save up for this wedding do you have an
emergency fund
yes i do how much is in there how many
months of expenses
um it's six months uh so but you don't
have many expenses
right so how much do you have in there
thirty thousand i've kind of put in like
a big chunk of my first year salary into
that very cool and you're investing 15
of your income into retirement
yep and uh maxed out my
401k that my employers sponsors so i
think i get like a seven percent match
wow so are you investing more than
fifteen percent
um i haven't looked into
that like it's not too specific um i'm
just trying to put in as much into you
know
investing i don't know the exact um
percentages okay well i would i would
keep it at 15 right now only because
you're 22 and you've got a lot of other
financial goals to hit including paying
for this wedding are you dating someone
right now or is this just future
thinking
um dating someone for like six years now
oh wow
so this this is like a high school
relationship
that has gone well
but not too well to where you're like
i'm not quite ready
right but i i just want to be uh
financially set as well dude you are do
i want to wait
well i just want to make sure you know
you have a 90 000 take-home pay you have
no debt in an emergency fund i mean half
the women listening right now are like
man i wish i could find a neil out there
yeah but um
this this wedding that i'm kind of
thinking of um kind of
in like the 500k kind of range but i'm
sorry hold the phones
you said 500 000 for a wedding
george have you ever been to indian
wedding i've seen it on tv
i've seen love is blind if that counts
oh my goodness man they're very
expensive
is that just normal
yeah hold on who's paying for this
sometimes
yeah so i don't want to get my parents
involved that's why i'm trying to kind
of do my due diligence to uh make these
steps proper and so i can pay for this
can you break the mold and do like a 50
000 wedding which is still like really
expensive for most people
yeah i mean maybe i can um
yeah i get it
man i mean that feels just exorbitant
for you to be paying
on your own i feel like it's like hey
mom and dad if this is your reputation
on the line then you can fund it right
but i've got goals
and the wedding is one day and i want to
set myself up for the rest of my life
with my wife not throw a party that
makes the parents look good
true
i mean right isn't that that's a piece
of the the cultural aspect
yeah um that is true but um usually
these like weddings like last like maybe
like a week long so it's not just one
day
um but yeah your logic definitely
doesn't make sense
man that just took my breath away i
think it took america's breath away too
i mean you could buy a house for that
much money
yeah um
yeah the the reputation really matters
though
well um i can't stop you from doing that
but i would say let's make a plan to
where you're not having to pay for that
because that's overwhelming for a 22
year old
even though you're crushing it to go hey
it's on you to pay for a half million
dollar wedding
yeah uh they did pay for my college
that's why i'm not kind of resorting to
asking my parents um but yeah that that
that does make sense
now have you talked to have you talked
to your girlfriend about her parents and
what they would pitch in
no so i'm kind of like early bird on
this um since i'm you know this is a
plan three four years out i
kind of don't want to freak her out by
mentioning you know marriage and stuff
um no i haven't hold on you've been
dating for six years and you think
you're going to freak her out by
mentioning marriage
but we're still 22 at the end of the day
you know uh we just got out the college
lifestyle uh working corporate jobs now
so it's not you know fully into the
picture yet now does she come from the
same cultural background as you
yes
okay so you're both on board to just
throw half million at this wedding
pretty much yeah now culturally is it
usually a split amount that families pay
how does this normally go down
yeah so normally it is split among the
uh bride's parents and the groom's
parents so the
bride and groom don't usually um
like pay for the expenses for the
wedding and that's where my head is at i
mean if the parents want to do that
that's great but if you say hey they're
not going to foot the bill and it's on
me then sorry we're not doing a half
million dollar wedding
yeah that doesn't make sense yeah
because here's the problem if you're
gonna do a half million dollar wedding
and pay for it you're gonna have to live
with your parents until the day you get
married
and that's not a good plan
so i think you need to move out you need
to start your life on your own you need
to have some more serious conversations
with your girlfriend as you head towards
marriage
and we've got to figure out a game plan
for what this future looks like and i i
mean it just hurts my heart that there's
half a million dollar weddings out there
i mean they look amazing don't get me
wrong i would love to be invited to one
one day so throw me an invite neil if
you're gonna throw the party that's
great and you're footing the bill
but man you're crushing it i mean 22
years old with a 90 000 take-home pay no
debt emergency fund you're investing
you're doing great and you can afford to
move out and get your own place if you
want to
uh and i wouldn't be sticking around
with mom and dad too much longer
gotcha make
sense all right well my work here is
done uh keep me posted on this wedding
send me photos and videos on instagram
all right neil
of course thank you george appreciate it
oh
i just had to deflate after that call i
literally can't breathe
trying to fathom spending five hundred
thousand dollars
so fun fact me and my wife
we won a free wedding that was a 28 000
wedding package and i mean i thought we
won the lottery
but it turns out that was like a poor
person sweating compared to these wild
indian weddings that are a week long
that's incredible and on top of that it
still cost us money to throw another
reception because the wedding had limits
on how many people could attend and all
that so you were down you know four
guests can attend and so we threw
another reception
that we helped pay for with with you
know our families and it was great and
it was worth it but man let me tell you
i don't remember much from the wedding
except the photos
i don't i can't tell you i can count on
one finger how many times i've went back
and watched the wedding footage and
reminisced because the truth is the
focus is now on our marriage together
just us two
couldn't tell you who was there and all
the faces and invitations we sent out uh
kelly was there she's pointing at me now
reminding me that she was there
appreciate you kelly thanks for the gift
whatever it was
but man weddings the whole thing is a
scam and i get that we love to celebrate
and it's a big day for people but
remember
it's about you too it's about your
marriage it's about your future it's not
about impressing people it's not about
keeping up a reputation this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show you
probably knew that but i'm going to
remind you anyways i'm george campbell
your host today ramsay personality and
host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcasts
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every single
month you'll save even more and you guys
know i love to save you can use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from darren in
nevada
he says how do i get out of a hole that
just keeps getting deeper
i worked two jobs and made seventy two
thousand dollars last year
between child support a school loan and
rent that just keeps going up i'm barely
keeping my head above water
i've been following you for over three
years i even became a financial coach to
have as a side gig but that didn't work
out
i'm frustrated and tired it's hard doing
this alone and i've created a social
bubble around myself which is also
wearing me down what can i do to move
forward
darren i feel so much weight in your
question
you're in a really really tough spot
right now
and i don't want to belittle that or
make light of it
this stuff is hard
but here's the thing about things that
are hard
being in debt is hard
being financially disciplined
getting out of debt is hard and so we've
got to choose which hard we want and a
lot of people unfortunately choose the
type of hard that leaves them in debt
for
10 20 30 years and they're broke in
retirement
and they lived a house of cards and it
comes tumbling down eventually
and so the heart that you're describing
is the hard
that's worth it
where you see the light at the end of
the tunnel and right now it's hard to
see it's hard to see that you can't see
the forest from the trees but that child
support one day
will be gone
the school loan soon enough if you
follow the baby steps and use the debt
snowball will be gone that rent that
just keeps going up is gonna be gone
because eventually you're gonna get into
a house with a fixed payment which
you're going to pay off
and so your mortgage payment will be
gone
so what you need to do right now is try
to have a vision beyond friday
have a vision for the next two three
five ten years of your life
where you remind yourself
why you're sacrificing right now
and you mentioned that you've created a
social bubble around yourself i assume
you're talking about the fact that
you're working so hard you don't have
any relationships you feel disconnected
and on that front i would encourage you
to get plugged in to a financial peace
university class
if you get in a group of people who are
on the same journey you are it changes
everything
because you have people who get it who
are speaking the same language who can
encourage you when you feel like giving
up
who can cheer you on with every little
piece of progress you make it changes
everything so try to join a class in
person if you can you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and get plugged in
to a class there
and you also said how do i get out of a
hole that just keeps getting deeper so
my hope is that you're not continuing to
go into debt because of your situation
that's kind of a baby step zero where we
decide we're done borrowing no matter
what we're gonna get creative we're
gonna work extra we're gonna cut the
expenses down so that we can stop going
into debt and start paying it off
so we're cheering you on man i wish i
could talk to you and hear more about
your story uh but until you call in i
hope that encourages you in the meantime
let's go to the phones this hour it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five hugo joins us in
dallas texas hugo welcome to the ramsay
show
hi george hey
what's going on
um so i had a question uh in regards to
the car market right now
um
i've been looking for a car for about
six six seven months now
um and i haven't had like much luck for
it um i am a firm believer in uh
not taking uh any loans for for a car
payment at the dealership um i have cash
uh saved up for a car i just don't know
if i should wait uh until the car market
goes down a little bit or if it's the
right time to to buy a car
how much do you have save for the car
uh i have about 8 or 9k
okay
and are you out of debt with a fully
funded emergency fund
um yes i have no debt uh and i have a
thousand for uh emergency fund
okay so we're in baby step three right
now
all right correct you gotta save up to
three to six months of expenses
what's going on with your car that's
that's causing this urgency to get a new
one
um so the car i i had before uh the
transmission one now
uh it's an it's an o4 acura so um if i
fix the transmission it's probably like
another 2k so 2k is pretty much what the
car is kind of worth it does have a high
mileage right now so um i don't want to
really fix the car right now in the rest
of the transmission
um so i'm really just looking forward
for a new car here now
okay so could you sell this thing right
now how much would you get for it about
2k with the transmission being busted
um i would say if
if anything maybe like 1k
in this market you could probably sell
it for parts more than that things are
crazy out there right now
i would do some research i mean you're
you're not in a terrible place because
you don't have debt and so there's not a
lot of desperation here but can you you
can't drive right now right
uh no i can't i i uh i borrowed uh my
dad's car for school and work right now
so
um it's it's kind of
i am kind of in a tight spot but i don't
want to lose my head and get a car
payment loan uh because i've been
watching uh the rams show for three
years now so i know everything we teach
about
cool well do you know what kind of car
you're looking to get for eight or nine
k
uh yeah um so i'm looking either toyota
or honda and then just the luxury
versions of those which would be the
lexus and the acura
okay
yeah i mean with eight or nine i'm
probably gonna go with the honda toyota
because if you're going lexus or acura
you're gonna end up where you were when
where you have a luxury car that is more
expensive to maintain and i'm a big fan
those are the only four brands i love in
that space
because of the reliability
but i still would be looking at
something cheaper right now especially
as you try to build this emergency fund
because right now if you had an
emergency you'd be screwed
even though you're out of debt
and um i don't know this is a factor too
um
all the cars i've looked at have rebuilt
and salvage titles so i don't know if
that's also i wouldn't do that
okay unless you're a mechanic i wouldn't
be buying a car that has a rebuilt or
savage title there's too much
that we don't know about what happened
and frame damage and if it's safe to
drive and what could go wrong with it so
if i'm you i'm not going to a dealership
because you're not going to get a deal
at a dealership right now they're all
going to charge you over msrp when they
find out you're paying cash they're
going to charge you even more because
they're not making money off the deal
versus financing so if i'm you i'm going
to facebook marketplace i'm going to
craigslist and i'm going to someone
saying hey you have it listed for 10
i'll give you 8 500 cash today
and you commit and you show up and you
get it make sure you whatever you look
at you get it inspected by a mechanic
before you purchase it
pre-purchase inspection is what you want
to do it'll cost you you know 100 bucks
but man it's going to give you some
peace of mind
before you turn around and call me and
say i bought a ten thousand dollar car
that's a lemon what do i do
so if i was in your shoes that's what
i'd be doing i don't think you're gonna
find an eight or nine thousand dollar
car at a reputable dealership you may be
able to get one through an auto broker
or wholesaler that can find you a good
deal on something reliable
but i would get us something as cheap as
possible to get you from a to b get your
emergency fund saved up try to sell your
car for as much as you can get for it
and then eventually we upgrade once
we're in baby step four through six
okay no it sounds good i can definitely
go ahead and do that yeah the key here
is doing your research and being patient
and it may take another month or two
before you find that the right car but
don't do things out of desperation
here's how i like to look at it the
person with the most patience the most
information always wins and the most
options and so when you only have two
options
that sucks we need more options when
it's really urgent and you're really
desperate that sucks
when you have no patience that sucks so
take your time do a lot of research
online always get it inspected don't do
anything out of desperation always pay
cash try to negotiate and you'll be just
fine man thanks for the call this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
ecclesiastes 4 9.
two are better than one because they
have a good return
for their labor
helen keller once said walking with a
friend in the dark is better than
walking alone
in the light
[Music]
folks if you're out there listening we
get it
there's a lot of people struggling with
money right now and it can be
all-consuming you're wondering if that
checks gonna clear if you can even
afford to fill up at the gas station
it's always on your mind
but you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress and you don't have to
when you follow a proven plan you'll
discover peace with your money in
financial peace university you'll learn
the same plan that's helped almost 10
million people budget save and spend
wisely pay off debt and build wealth
you can start watching the course online
right now or join a class with others
for community and support
decide today that you're done letting
money stress rule your life you can do
this start financial peace university
for free by visiting ramsey solutions
dot com
slash fpu that's ramsay solutions dot
com slash fpu
douglas joins us up next in los angeles
douglas welcome to the show
hi thanks george i appreciate you guys
advice so much and live by it even
though i'm not part of the program oh
that means a lot anyhow
yeah that's that's so so good um my mom
is 93 and in good shape she has a living
trust
i stand to be the the one-third that
inherits the house needs a lot of work i
do plan on living there i'd like to fix
it up and even even put a pool in it
because we're in southern california hot
should i wait until i'm here at the
house to start putting some money into
that myself or
or should she quit deed it to me now or
what do you think is the best plan
[Music]
that that is quite the predicament here
so are you going to own the house solely
yes my brothers both have agreed to give
me the house if i want it and
they'll take the other can there's like
800 900 000
that's divided between them
okay i would get that piece in writing
just so that when it when it comes down
to it i don't want them to go well hold
on hold on the house prices have
increased and man i want in on this
house now so if you guys are going to
have that kind of arrangement i would
have in writing not because you don't
trust each other but because you
actually love each other and you want to
avoid that kind of conflict
thank you okay great advice so where are
you at financially are you out of debt
do you have a fully funded emergency
fund yeah my yeah i have an emergency
fund my home's paid off my cars are paid
up i don't have too much of
any payments anymore wow i have a condo
that i own too
that gives me some rental income but you
know i don't have a ton of money in the
bank but i have a good living condition
so you have a paid for house and a paid
for condo
yes douglas my man you are crushing it
so beyond that you only have your
emergency fund
as far as cash that's about it yeah yeah
well with with where you're at
financially how much of your income
could you sock away for a renovation
fund
uh probably about
four to five thousand a month somewhere
in there
okay
what we could do is just start stocking
that money away and when that time comes
and when that house is yours you have a
big pile of renovation money that you've
used intentionally for that
right so i don't know that i would start
it right now
it feels a little bit uh weird because
she's still living there and obviously
she's she's crushing it at 93. i hope
i'm in that shape i hope i'm alive at
93. but i would hold off and wait
because we just don't know what life
looks like we don't know if she's gonna
live another seven years and so to be
putting a pool in the backyard of a
place that isn't really yours it just
feels a little bit premature
i see
and it wouldn't be in her my best
interest for her to quit eat it to me if
my brothers agreed now or anything like
that
i mean you have a paid for property and
so you got a place to live you know when
she passes you've got time to make those
renovations you know in in three months
time you could have all of that done
while you hang out at your place and
you know there's there's just a lot of
life ahead of you guys
and i wouldn't quit deed it immediately
there's no need for that i mean you
could if you wanted to
but you still won't be living there and
so
there still leaves that kind of uh that
kind of issue so i think with where
you're at financially there's no need to
start this right now but i would say
start putting the money away in a
savings account 5 000 a month that's 60
grand a year
and in two years that's 120 grand and
now we can have some fun with some
renovations because of your financial
spot
awesome okay that's awesome yeah man
thanks for the call i expected great
advice and i got it oh that means a lot
i appreciate the call man
robert is up next he's in sacramento
california robert welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you for taking my call george
thanks for having a wonderful day i am
how are you
i'm doing well it's a nice warm day um
i've got first i want to um encourage
the the
the uh
email of the day guy uh i've been there
man uh
keep chipping away you know as you dig
yourself out that hole fills up
and just keep at it you'll get you'll
get out man
my question is i've
paid off all my debt i've made through
baby step three my fully funded
emergency fund and i'm at that point
where i need to i want to either
go and start at my 3b
or initiate my um investment
and i'm not quite sure how much to put
into
3b or just to explain halfway between 3b
and 4. yeah that's a great question and
there are a few ways you can go and this
is a very personal uh thing for a lot of
people either you
pause
investing entirely and you just go all
in on 3b
for you know maybe a year or two i don't
like going much further than that or you
split the difference and go hey i'm
going to invest up to the match or i'm
going to invest you know five percent
six percent and then the rest is gonna
go to three b
or we begin investing fifteen percent
and whatever's left goes towards three b
so it depends on the urgency of you
getting into a house how urgent is this
uh not very urgent uh where i'm renting
is a very below market value for rent so
um
yeah so
thanks for that i was able to get out of
debt and do my snow fall uh
stuff faster so yeah so if you pause
investing i can't beat that how fast
could you save up
uh
[Applause]
at least
three thousand dollars a month okay so
it's 36 a year so in two years you'd
have 72.
yeah would that be a reasonable down
payment of 10 to 20 percent for a place
in your area that is reasonable
well um
in some places in the area it's kind of
like on a stop on the way to tahoe so
we've had a lot of bay area transplants
kind of drive prices up quite a bit
do you have to live close to that area
no i've just been in the area because
it's
where i got cheaper so i was hoping for
a cheaper house um is your work nearby
yes i'm about 15 minutes driving
distance from work okay that's good i
like to stay close to work that's just a
personal preference don't love a commute
so if you can find something that's
close to where you work that's
reasonable and i would start doing your
research to know what you're aiming at
all right my goal is to have eighty
thousand dollars saved up in two years
i'm gonna pause investing and then i'm
gonna get into that house and begin
investing 15
so how old are you okay
i am 38. okay have you invested at all
so far
no i have a 401k available to work uh
but due to some uh changes in the
contract
uh it's no longer matched and i'd be
putting my first dollars in in six years
oh so so you have zero dollars in
retirement right now
correct okay
well i mean that changes my feelings
about if i'm in your shoes and i'm 38
and i don't want to work till 72 i want
you to begin investing
and so if that's the case i would be
investing 15 and it's going to slow down
your progress towards the down payment
but that's that's the
trade-off we have to make
because we haven't invested you know in
38 years of life and so
i think we put we just put a pause here
and we go all right it's going to be
more like four years before i can get
into that house instead of two and i'm
okay with that i'm renting below market
hopefully it stays that way i can afford
it my income should go up i can work
extra to make this thing happen
but right now i would be focused on
getting that 15
so that in 20 25 years from now when you
retire you can be a millionaire
[Music]
it sounds great awesome appreciate the
call robert that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
all the nice people in the booth that
made this show happen today kelly ben
james
zach nathan the whole gang and you
america we appreciate you listening we
can't do the show without you remember
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you